o
[Música]
boa tarde é eu sou a marize azeredo e o
sou pedagoga trabalho como diretora da
mocidade espírita legião do bém melby
sou pedagoga do studio de danças pelo
sim azeredo e assim a minha vida sempre
teve a arte como ponto fundamental vamos
colocar assim é a meu bi
sempre que é a gente trata muito a
melvin como mais pela fila que a
mocidade espírita legião do bém ea elbe
é sempre trabalhou com arte e
praticamente eu nasci dentro dessa casa
e trabalhando com a ti meu pai foi
cantor
a minha mãe escreveu muitas peças
teatrais principalmente espíritas e eu
sempre estive envolvida com arte
quando eu tive meus filhos que assim
azeredo o início
os dois também partiram para o meu
caminho da arte né ela é bailarina
educadora física e proprietário do
studio de danças e o meu filho estuda
cinema em brasília então a família toda
envolvida com arte e essa arte pra quê
pra podermos levar é abrir um caminho
pra as crianças e os jovens
então começamos um trabalho dentro da
casa com jovens crianças e jovens a
partir dos três aos 18 anos
e esse trabalho é voltado para a dança
mas pra que essa dança não fosse só eu
chegar aqui no palco maravilhoso como
esse me apresentar
não seria também para que eu pudesse
estar neste palco uma moda mostrar os
meus sentimentos
o meu sentimento de amor ao que faz de
amor à dança ou a qualquer outra arte
que você goste que você queira e esse
trabalho passou a ser é o trabalho muito
voltado com a família das crianças
também porque não adianta você querer
fazer um trabalho com uma criança com o
adolescente e que a família não teve
acordo
né não vamos chegar a lugar nenhum então
a gente começa a fazer um trabalho
ligado deles com a família é começamos
com seis crianças apenas e hoje em dia
nós temos 350 crianças e adolescentes é
eles vão todos os sábados nosso trabalho
é só nos sábados pra pra melby nós
trabalhamos de oito da manhã até às 18
horas da tarde e com várias turmas e
essas crianças que entraram crianças que
hoje já são jovens alguns já são adultos
eles não quiseram sair porque seria de 3
a 18 anos né mas eles não queriam sair
não tinha eu não quero sair
eu não tenho aqui a minha casa também
então eu quero ficar e aí nós passamos a
fazer um trabalho voltado
a profissional é profissionalização
deles para que esse sonho que eles
tinham de dançar não se perdesse
aí no caminho e começamos a trabalhar
com eles é isso que você quer para sua
vida é isso é mesmo vamos conversar
vamos chegar a um ponto comum não tinha
é isso que eu quero pra minha vida eu
quero ser bailarina eu quero ser
professora de dança é eu quero trabalhar
com as crianças também então vamos
seguir um caminho e hoje temos a
professora já que o nosso trabalho é
voluntário e no início era muito difícil
você conseguir alguém que se dispusesse
está lá é no horário fixo e não ter nada
em troca a gente brinca assim que não te
à parte
de um salário de uma ajuda de custo
esse é um trabalho voluntário então às
vezes ficava difícil até as pessoas às
vezes criam mas não tinham como se
locomover e a instituição também não tem
é não trabalha não trabalhamos com com a
parte financeira
o nosso trabalho todo é voluntário então
o que é que vamos fazer já que esses
jovens querem seguir esse caminho então
vamos dar oportunidade para que eles
possam seguir fazer uma faculdade fazer
um curso técnico e começamos a trabalhar
assim
então algumas foram o curso técnico de
balé clássico na ufpa é outras
efe fizera graduação algumas estão
terminando uma já terminaram a graduação
e como conseguimos é resgatar também
essa parte né de você também ter a parte
profissional junto e aquela coisa de que
o coxa é o meu sonho e eu não tenho como
realizá lo tem é só você querer né
é claro que às vezes você precisa de um
empurrãozinho de uma ajuda aqui uma
ajuda de lá mas é possível realizar seus
sonhos e eu fico muito feliz quando eu
vejo um aluno chega com miguézim tia eu
estou realizando meu sonho
o marize eu estou realizando meu sul que
o meu sonho era ser bailarina
então eu estou começando a realizá lo na
realidade porque você ser uma bailarina
tem um caminho bem grande ainda aí pela
frente né mas é é muito gratificante pra
gente quando a gente vê las no palco
vendas bem pequenininhas com com três
anos
e e elas mostrarem a vontade está aqui
neste palco ou no palco do theatro da
paz e felicidade para elas quando a
gente consegue uma pauta no teto da paz
é uma alegria imensa porque algumas no
início
nunca tinha entrado no teatro nunca
tinha oportunidade de editar na platéia
quanto mais no palco né e hoje em dia
elas têm essa oportunidade de estarem
dançando no palco e isso é atrelado a
todo um trabalho que é feito por mim
pelas professoras de que quando a gente
escolhe a música nós vamos trabalhar
essa música essa música trabalhada com
as crianças é colocado para elas o que
diz a música porque aí elas vão sentir
né quando eu sei o que eu estou dançando
o que eu vou mostrar eu posso sentir e
adams
isso é um sentimento que é seu e que no
momento que você se apresenta é passado
para a platéia ea platéia assente também
o que eu tô querendo levar o que eu
estou querendo dizer então é partimos
pra profissionaliza las
e aí começamos a ir para são paulo
elas participam do mostra dança que é um
o curso que acontece no mês de janeiro
em são paulo e lá eles têm as aulas
normais ballet clássico jazz sapateado
além de ter as aulas pro já
profissionalizando pra você ser
realmente um professor de dança
então elas também fazem esse curso
algumas já completaram o ciclo todo
porque são vários ciclos
algumas estão iniciando além desse curso
em são paulo nós participamos já aos 6
anos do festival de dança de joinville
inclusive dançando nos palcos de
joinville que a nós é uma felicidade
muito grande porque é um festival muito
concorrido
vem gente de fora do brasil ele é
internacional e graças a deus todas as
vezes a gente manda é os vídeos nós
fomos aprovados
então isso aí pra gente é gratificante é
uma felicidade imensa e a partir do ano
passado não do ano retrasado 2016
nós tivemos a satisfação de ter a
seletiva do bolshoi em belém e com isso
facilitou muito pra gente pra que as
meninas pudessem todas participarem
porque não precisava pagar passagem
estamos aqui né então um ano de 2016
nós tivemos cinco alunos aprovados e
para a seletiva nacional
chegamos na seletiva nacional eram 2.550
candidatos né e nós éramos cinco na
humilde vizinhos pequeninos mas
estávamos lá
uma fotógrafa de lado e choi tirou fotos
das crianças e se olha que legal porque
vocês vieram uniformizados porque já
tivemos vou fazer uma camisa é eu fui né
aí seletiva o show nacional com muito
legal e assim
dos 11 que foram porque foram 11
aprovados só que nem todos éramos eram
alunos nós mas foram conosco é dos
nossos cinco foram aprovados
e assim foi uma felicidade muito grande
é assim a gente ficava esperando porque
eram três etapas ea primeira etapa vai
ser o resultado não sair saiu e aí foi
aprovada em segunda etapa novamente
aquela ansiedade pra ver o que acontecer
e na terceira etapa graças a deus e sim
foram aprovados e com muita luta porque
o show ele só dá as aulas alimentação no
período que estão lá dentro
a condução até os 12 anos depois eles
não só vale o vale-transporte e mais a
casa eles não dão e aí que a gente vai
fazer agora fomos aprovado temos que é e
vamos dar um jeito e vai rir e vamos pra
praça e faz isso faz aquilo e graças a
deus
os cinco foram os cinco residem e
joinville e o ano passado tivemos mais
duas aprovadas inclusive uma que não foi
aprovada no primeiro ano foi pra lá foi
até a última etapa e não conseguiu
e assim eu vou falar sobre ela porque
pra mim foi muito emocionante e eu me
emociono muito quando eu falo
porque ela só tinha nove anos ano
passado
na realidade em 2016 e ela olhou pra mim
e disse tia não foi dessa vez mas ano
que vem eu volto e eu vou passar e
quando ela fez o ano passado a seletiva
belém
assim a gente estava muito conversamos
muito com ela fizemos um trabalho com
ele com a família porque de repente ela
poderia não passar né ea gente faz
também o trabalho de lado com as
crianças
justamente por isso para que elas não
sofram né a dança a arte é felicidade é
alegria e sentimento
às vezes nem às vezes você precisa
mostrar um sentimento não tão bom mas
você precisa ter consciência daquilo e
ano passado ela fez foi aprovada de novo
vamos para jogar video novamente e será
que vai acontecer e quando deu resultado
ela foi aprovada quando ela chegou eu
não fui com ela foi a minha filha que
foi quando eu cheguei quando ela chegou
ela chegou comigo se eu te falei falei
que ia passar dessa vez e agora eu vou
já voam a minha mala
não calma que só em fevereiro mas a
ansiedade dela era tão grande para
instalar que a família dela não pode nem
dizer que não ia
e graças a deus ela está lá está muito
bem é o bolshoi também ajuda na escola
pública né
a ed carlos pra escola pública então
graças a deus que estão lá estão bem tão
satisfeitos também temos um aluno que
está no rio é dançando também
trabalhando numa outra área mas não
largou a dança né e também fez um em são
paulo já tivemos e mexe passado eram 15
em são paulo e os outros voltaram e este
ficou lá batalhando tatames fazendo
rifas estamos fazendo isso porque ele
ganhou uma bolsa pra itália
só que tenha passagem alimentação é ea
coisa fica às vezes um pouco difícil mas
vamos conseguir né aquele lá de cima não
desampara ninguém e os sonhos eles são
criados na nossa mente e nos ajudam a
realizá-los a correr atrás dele
nunca diga eu tinha um sonho não eu
tenho um sonho e eu vou conseguir
realizá lo
não importa em que momento não posso
tratar de bem da bem velhinha e posso
conseguir realizar esse sonho
então nunca diga não aos seus sonhos de
sempre conseguir risada porque muito
importantes que você faça o que você
gosta
eu sou da seguinte opinião eu acho que
quando você faz o que gosta
por mais que aquilo até não vá de dar
uma vida mais tranquila te dá um avô ter
uma mansão vou ter carlos vou ter isso
mas o importante é fazer o que você
gosta porque aí sim você será
profissional
feliz e quando você é feliz
você passa a sua felicidade para os
outros e aí todos nós acabamos sendo
felizes e é isso que importa
estamos aqui estamos no brasil vivendo
uma situação difícil mas vamos dançar
vamos correr atrás dos nossos sonhos e
vamos ser felizes porque é isso que
importa
a felicidade está aqui dentro de cada um
de nós pode procurar encontrar e vai ser
feliz e vai realizar aquele sonho que às
vezes está guardado mas que ele pode ser
é revivido e vamos conquistá los porque
é muito bom quando a gente é um
profissional feliz eu posso dizer que eu
sou uma profissional muito feliz porque
só então tá com os ovos com as crianças
nesse trabalho é gratificante que é você
poder orientar você transformar a vida
de crianças da periferia
então só isso já valeu tudo pra mim
mostrar para eles que eles podem que
eles podem ser diferentes
eles podem consegui e é é muito bom
quando você vê como máscara e vocês
verão as meninas algumas alunas mostrar
o seu sonho e que ele pode ser realizado
e que a gente nunca pode dizer não a
gente sempre tem que dizer um sim sempre
o que é bom o sim para o meu irmão que
está do meu lado e que às vezes está
precisando de uma força da torcida
geninho está precisando de um carinho de
um aperto de mão e um abraço
e é isso que vou falar pra vocês é um
pouquinho eu me emociono muito meu filho
fala assim não se emocione mas o teve
jeito
obrigada